[Music]
44 seconds of logos Comcast my husband
used to tell me I have an overactive
imagination huh that's funny
my wife used to tell me that movies
didn't always begin with overactive
narration so you can see the area I mean
haven't you ever been on a train and
wondered about the lives of the people
who live near the tracks I mean I guess
I didn't know you could make a whole
movie about it I suppose I started
noticing her about a year ago or
whenever she began prancing around the
balcony of her house and super skimpy
bedroom attire also discount Jennifer
Lawrence really looks like Jennifer
Lawrence like I feel bad for her that
genetically she's stuck looking like
another actress that got famous a few
years earlier than she bit also also I
just realized this movie is a mass
transit based rear window and that
honestly kind of pisses me off
she became important to me me too I mean
look at her
I mean I'm not attracted to her or
anything I'm just a third party observer
observing her balcony nuts and nothing
else she's what I lost she's everything
I want to be what's truly amazing is
this chick is always outside at the
exact times Rachel passes by on the
train in order for her to construct
narratives about a stranger chances are
you'd see this woman like twice a month
if that it's daytime again and I just
now realized this movie is doing some
kind of stream-of-consciousness thing
regarding her commute but you can't
blame me for expecting a regular
narrative after three confusing passes
by the knot Jennifer Lawrence's house
movie decides to adopt a traditional
narrative and starts following emily
Blunt's day movie seriously needs to
pick a direction and go with it already
I imagine she's a painter this is one of
those book adaptations where the
characters have to read the book aloud
for you to understand what's going on
isn't it also she just drew Heath Ledger
and Michelle Williams and you will never
convince me otherwise I wonder what they
say to each other before they go to
sleep they say I wonder if some creepy
ass chick on the train that passes our
house is obsessed with us ah surely not
that's what they say if only they knew
train visible house sex I used to live
two doors down sudden reveal that you
used to live next door to this house
you're trained stalking is sudden every
day I tell myself not to look because
they're always ready with personally
painful things to show her in the window
no matter what time of day she rides
past them maybe some huge lady who said
that before you even got a look at that
baby you are a phony phony as if the
slurred speech and probable liquor
breath weren't enough for this woman she
gets an orgy of evidence that rachel is
a
by seeing the minibar on her lap when
that recent mother go did she imagine
her I did that lady disappear quickly
and quietly or does the movie want to
tie us up and worrying about this so we
missed the larger story points gorilla
on a train sips a thing and I'm ready to
roll credits man no like Megan
I mean teacher once told me I was a
mistress of self reinvention huh that's
funny
my auto mechanic once told me that
movies don't over stress self narration
so you can see the irony movie does
nothing but put me for seven minutes and
then throws me directly into a therapy
session I tend to smile when I'm nervous
sometimes I laugh sometimes I wear a
sexy white dress to therapy for a year
Mac and I lived in this hunting cabin
look just because you're saying this to
a psychologist does not make it not
narration we started okay oh go on
you were saying god dammit stop
introducing girls I went and I brought
you packed bed with me know when I was
feeding you you heard daddy singing from
the kitchen in the way narrating life to
your toddler another gallery had hunted
me this might be the cockiest sounding
thing ever said in the movie another
gallery headhunted you so you're so
fucking awesome it might presume picking
paintings that go together for exhibits
that you're being headhunted frequently
this movie wants me to hate this girl
right because I do what are you doing
you meet my baby gotta say I've read the
book and I know what the scene means in
context and still watching this movie is
confusing
ah roses for the wife who did you come
the way home today IVF rarely works the
first time easy ass baby related
marriage tension back story is easy ass
I know it she's looking at Megan has set
the record in 19 minutes mind you for
number of times out on her deck or
backyard at any given time for anyone in
the history of the world movie firmly
establishes Rachel's alcoholism but
hardly any reason to keep watching the
movie Anna I fell asleep last night
thing interview who's Anna again she the
pretty blonde or the other pretty blonde
or wait is she another woman I think
this movie did show us an aunt a title
card a minute ago but who the fuck knows
who's who I realized that they were
kisses not exes and my husband was
century two what I wanted you know don't
you have to either be paid buy or pay
century 21 to use their name like this
and given the context I'm guessing they
weren't interested in a paid product
placement merging their agents so how
did this come to be
in that post everything
are you mad about the adultery or the
wasted interior decorating skills I'd
wrap my hand in a long blonde hair on a
joke ahead black just chuck it back you
know kind of like a certain future
murderer that's about to happen that
will incriminate me
these are lethal leaving Las Vegas
levels of drunken depression depiction
oh she's going to go to that house she's
been spying on this movie is a solid PSA
for not drinking too much before making
drastic life decisions but this story
happened we have to have a woman who
obsesses over strangers who just
happened to live a couple houses away
from her old house the obsession over
Megan and her husband Scott is rather
remarkable considering the main fixation
is over her ex-husband Tom and his new
wife Anna on the very day drunken Rachel
decides to confront Megan over another
man she thinks she saw her with she just
happens to be out for a stroll in the
neighborhood and she's about to get
murdered by spoiler alert someone Rachel
knows also continuing more ranting the
whole movie is also possible because she
passes out and wakes up alone with some
wounds and blood not knowing what
happened you movie I'm not playing your
detective games just show me the movie
and stop in with me at this point I'm
ready to blame everything here on Ben
Affleck and that just doesn't seem right
regardless of recent drama using a
smartphone in a tub is just asking for
trouble
did that really happen or was that a
dream or fantasy you don't know you
don't know
remember when you open with three
women's names and two separate
narrations in the first 12 minutes but
then spent the next 20 VOCA seing solely
on this one girl what the fuck was that
about Rachel she's a former friend on
this train who was here just at the
right time to get proper character
development in context via flashbacks
after witnessing this Golf Club attack
from the past yeah I think the
unreliable narrator thing is in full
effect here
also even Tiger Woods is jealous of that
swing if only because she didn't break
her back and have to withdraw from the
tournament despite her wonky swing
cutting from the golf club attacked or
her walking at night in the street is
basically everything wrong with this
movie and it's you editing and
sequencing style
when is this whew you don't deserve to
know it's my understanding you were
fired from that job over a year ago
because of your drinking problem girls
drinking problem is so bad she has
memory issues calling into question
everything I've seen so far making me
think the movies definition of
unreliable narrator is actually a
hand-drawn picture of a hand drinking
off a middle finger you don't remember
anything do you Laura pretty fun would
be excellent at being a character and
Bourne Ultimatum Rachel is remembering
an embrace between Megan and a man she
doesn't know but there's no way she was
able to zoom into a close-up of that
dude especially after drinking that
heavily it's pretty coincidental isn't
it you just happened to be on a train at
the same exact moment that a woman you
don't know but somehow recognize is
cheating on her husband movie itself
would be excellent at cinema since mrs.
Watson reported that you go to their
house sometimes uninvited only now after
Rachel's run out of the house to
specifically tell detective Riley about
Megan's affair does Riley tell her this
is a huge head only it's a fake trip
where nothing is holy mother of God what
was I talking about he figures out all
my passwords if you have half a brain
that shouldn't be possible you Megan's
friend yes Rachel lying while snooping
snoop lying snoop lining I saw your wife
with someone on Friday morning none of
this seems weird to Scott a random woman
coming to his house who feels compelled
to meet in person to tell him something
from his perspective she apparently did
not tell the police the alcoholic chick
who might already be drinking again is
definitely drinking again
this should make her even more reliable
Saturday you saw the answer is yes but
there's no way Rachel knows that I
remember that's him
Oh two months ago from four months ago
from present day from when movie doesn't
care
okay she asks where are you into the
phone and we cut to her having sex in
the woods with the dude that we don't
get a good enough look at to know who it
is and this is what's wrong with this
fucking tease of a movie and with that
Meghan won the argument then they
immediately boned with something that
comes after this but not this for the
first time in ages I have purpose so I'm
playing pool these people have
apparently never heard of phone
conversations or simple texts why the
fuck did I have to keep meeting like
this I told them I'm abusive well you
probably are but we only know that from
Meghan's words so maybe you weren't
which is kind of the problem with the
cops just accepting everything that
they're possessed which is what they
appear to have done and she walked out I
didn't go after I never call to check on
her yeah why is that actually is it
because this movie wants me to spend
time thinking every character in this
movie is guilty I think it is yep that's
your ex and his new wife and child
the very reason you were Cop ordered to
stay away from the street so why when
leaving Meghan's house did you walk in
this direction you stupid idiot do you
want to go to jail yo your wife hit me
on Friday night god damn this movie
every single thing it shows me it also
wants me to doubt just write a good
mystery in dear script and stop relying
on this unreliable character bullsh
cheap-shot tecnique Jesus got hip Paul's
house how the fuck would you know that
you only noticed her when she was
standing in the street a minute ago has
she been back to the house since the
incident was your child not that I know
what was she not at the house at have
seen five minutes ago I mean yeah maybe
her husband told her she was at Scott's
but if you're Anna do you believe for
one moment she's at Scott's without an
ulterior motive to see Tom believe it or
not this is mainly the second spouse
tries to break into spouses computer
records moment in this film the part is
from my yard everywhere I didn't know
where else to go
Wow okay first of all how did the
reporters not follow you here also did
she get this guy her address hey if you
ever need to talk about your problem we
did why if you can come by my apartment
didn't I even ever say anything about me
to you she loved you
what are you doing lady you haven't even
made two decisions in this movie that
making sense
boo be in with me put her on my chest
sudden dead baby story is sudden
also the story about how Megan went to
sleep in the tub with her kid is
heart-wrenching and gives her character
some added depth but at this point were
far beyond caring about stuff like this
it has nothing to do with the mystery at
all came with the frame rate to try and
make me feel tension only makes
me upset at you for fucking with the
framerate the front door was open it's
not like I broken leaving your front
door open in any New York state
residents insane but I just wanted to
hold her outside while walking away from
the house of course Megan was on the
balcony that day making the appearance
that she only makes when Rachel looks at
her house despite her many connections
to this case Rachel still thinks it's a
smart move to show up here right now
turns out I'm not the father neither is
the shrink who could it be
thank you you know for getting AB dick
to point the finger at me for getting
the cops to say that you and I are gay I
feel like maybe this thank-you is
disingenuous I'm going to file a
statement yeah here in the bathroom yes
but what I'm trying to determine is when
your obsession with mr. Hipwell began i
guess it's natural for someone like
rachel to lie about exactly how she
became obsessed with the hip wells
riding on a train all day drunk
inventing stories about strangers but
since they now think she's a crazy
alcoholic anyway why can't she just tell
the goddamn truth I need to see you on
the night Megan was murdered she called
someone I mean it's a complete mystery
using her iPhone
she called somebody's number something
that if he referred to the detective
handbook on page one paragraph one
sentence one says always check who
murdered people call on the night of
their death it's a great first rule
something these detectives either pissed
on or had mr. Keating as their teacher
during dead detective society now that
she's joined the audience and not having
any idea what's true and what's false
let's have her down some martinis
that'll bring clarity so now she thinks
she did it she's done a 180 on this
thing and she hasn't been anything but
drunken crazy the whole time so this is
just for the audience to put them and
now I'm sure this means that she didn't
do it
oi can you stand see this movie is a
dick surprise this guy was super abusive
we just haven't told you that yet
because it wouldn't be a whammy if we
did this movie hides its entire plot
behind a thin veil of its protagonists
poor and selective memory yeah Tom got
fired because he couldn't keep his dick
in his pants
wait was Tom fired for sexual harassment
or fired for actually having consensual
sex with coworkers because I'm not sure
that's a fireable offense unless he was
a supervisor or something Anna finds
what will soon prove to be Megan's phone
incriminating tom in the murder plot and
proving once again that Justin wasn't
thorough enough and a rummages through
this drawer of wires and finds a
compatible charger to Megan's phone in
world record time
by the way what scenario would led to
Meghan wandering around by the tunnel
and Tom driving his car here
this isn't far from their homes so this
isn't like some private meeting spot or
something and I think it's easily
walkable distance but sure makes it
harder for an unreliable witness to
remember what was going on no you've
gone remember earlier when we saw Rachel
in the red haired dude seemingly
following her yeah he was this far away
from her now she eventually went off the
beaten path but this movie is saying
that in the time it took her to go to
the tunnel yell at Megan and get
assaulted by Tom that he didn't see any
of that this movie should have been
called the girl who only makes bad
decisions if you look in the background
of this movie a train is seemingly
passing by and every scene having waited
for tons of trains in the New York area
I can tell you that the sheer amount of
trains coming and going in this movie is
the stuff of pure fantasy orgasms with
Megan's phone if he did kill Megan but
kept her phone he's stupider than
Affleck and gone girl when you call
9-1-1 they pretty much instantly know
where you are but this movie will make
it seem like all is lost when Tom turns
the phone off also whatever happened to
911 operators having a callback when
they get hung up on cuz he totally hung
up right after the operator said what is
the nature of your emergency and she
told me that you were fired because she
was seeing everyone in the office and
you were warned about that Tom stop
fucking everybody
none of these women can control
themselves around you also how many
diseases and kids does this guy have
anyway and is this dick made of
chocolate dip cherries or something just
when you cut any wings someplace
secluded and foggy where you can kill me
and dispose of my body with no witnesses
I'm pregnant there's a chance it could
be yours
Jesus everyone who sleeps with this guy
knows how abusive he is even if only
emotionally why would you spring
life-shattering news about your affair
no one knows about on a guy this violent
out in the middle of nowhere I kind of
feel like the detectives did a job on
this investigation he's not wearing any
gloves or anything
she was his nanny his former co-workers
all think he's a slutty asshole how was
he never even considered a suspect how
was there no DNA evidence I mean last we
saw the real-time West Wing lady she was
convinced Rachel did it in a way you
killed her this is so laughable it loses
all potential sinister eNOS I guess I
understand the whole I can't let her
tell on me motive for this apparent
imminent murder attempt but does he
think his chances of getting away with
everything go up or down with more women
he's slept with dying I've got to ask
having seen these kind of choke vests
played out in movies time
time again how the choker doesn't notice
the Chokey reaching for in acquiring
items they can pummel the choker over
the head whip understandably the Swiss
Army brand turned down an invitation to
sponsor the scene also I like how she
used the corkscrew I mean she was in a
panic sure but they're way better
stabbing devices all over that knife
this train is symbolic of all the times
Rachel was on a train and no one in the
neighborhood heard or saw any of this I
was obsessed with you and my ex-husband
murdered you so now visiting your grave
makes sense and is in no way creepy we
are tied forever now the three of us by
Tom's chlamydia
anything is possible because I am NOT
the girl I he used to be because after
all that dramatic in the self defense Co
killing giving up alcohol somehow even
easier than ever mr. Lance
[Music]
what happens if the engine stops we are
I think a bad day I'm having the worst
damn day of my whole damn life on behalf
of the people of Laketown I ask that you
honor your pledge to tell you to dump a
body in the marsh you dump them in the
marsh not where some guy from John
Hancock goes every Thursday they get a
blowjob I imagine she's a painter he's a
doctor or an architect he was a real
artistic guy sensitive a painter these
people are not your enemy we all have
one enemy and that's no lying is like
taking you to it only there's no boat
and you don't actually go anywhere Tommy
ah sleeping